Hey, everyone!
I just wanted to say a quick thank you to all our good humans across the globe who purchased an item from our surface level collection.
We're actually almost sold out. So if you're interested in checking it out, I would go soon.
I am wearing a
human good crewneck myself while in quarantine since it's been a bit chilly, and I have found it to be very warm and comforting.
I just wanted to say thank you again for believing in our message, for finding ways to practice empathy in our day to day lives,
and I hope you all stay safe,
and if you are interested in our items, stick around to the end of the video, and we'll give you a link.
Otherwise, enjoy the video.
"In my school, a girl wanted to commit suicide. A lot of people including myself were laughing
because we thought that she was joking.
She ended up doing it. I regret it."
"All my friends are very smart.
I came from a gifted program in middle school and ended up failing multiple classes in the past three years.
I've managed to hide this from my parents.
Only one person knows about my failed suicide attempts, stemming from my academic problems, and the constant berating from my parents."
"I'm really struggling to find my identity, and it feels as though,
everyone around me already knows theirs, almost like I'll never find who I really am."
"My friends all think that I'm happy 24/7. Yeah, I am miserable. Every minute of every day.
I feel like an outsider. I always make sure they are okay.
Yet, no one asked me if I am. I feel as though I can't talk to my friends. They wouldn't understand,
but they are the only people that I have."
"I used to listen to my parents fight every day when they thought I was asleep.
This made it hard for me to do things with my parents, because I knew that they were fighting."
Yeah, I grew up with both my parents and
I was always like embarrassed of that,
because a lot of the people that were in my school or my neighborhood didn't have both parents, but my parents fought a lot.
I resented my father for his anger and his frustration. I resented my mother for being sick and all of our money going towards
health care and,
and as a family you don't talk about often, because it's not, you're like, this is nobody's business what we're arguing about. We're good,
we're happy family. Look at all these pictures look at us, you know,
but it does it does affect you,  it does make it difficult.
"I am extremely self-conscious about my looks. There has been a time where I felt so ugly,
I considered ending my life because I thought if I wasn't pretty, there was no reason to be here."
This would have been my confession four years ago.
Not many people know, but I have attempted suicide
four times in my life,
because of the mental health issues that I have
struggled with and that I have dealt with in my life, and I'm so glad that
none of my attempts
were successful. I'm so happy that I'm here. Sometimes when you're in this headspace, you can be
deaf to
hearing people talk about who you are as a person, because all you care about is your appearance, and how you look, and it's
easier said than done to say that you shouldn't focus on that, but
it's true. And if you look at the people around you, people will believe that you're beautiful for who you are, and
ending your life just is not the answer at all.
"I was sexually molested by another classmate about four years ago, and I still can't find the courage to tell my parents.
Even if this happened four years ago, I still feel guilty for everything that happened."
I was molested growing up, and so I know that there is a lot of shame that you can carry, but
the longer that you hold that in, and you don't talk to someone about that, that guilt and that shame, it's going to
consume you, even if you feel like you're managing it, okay, it can turn into anxiety.
It can haunt you in the night, and you have to talk to somebody about that. I know that there's a lot of fear,
especially about being believed, and how people will react, but like I believe you, and it is not your fault.
"Whenever my parents compared me to other kids because of how much better they are, I think of wanting to vanish or run away,
because they deserve a better child."
Okay,
I should read this aloud, sorry.
"I bullied my transitioning best friend until he killed himself.
After he died, I felt terrible. I couldn't sleep, couldn't eat, and to this day, carry the burden of his death on my shoulders.
I regret it, but I never told anyone."
"It started in seventh grade. I was bullied. Extremely insecure, simply just not happy.
I had been cutting, starving, whatever I could do to punish myself for being me."
Reminds me of my past,
way before I was even born.
The doctors had told my parents that "That child has a 5% chance of survival," and throughout those surgeries,
I ended up having so many scars all over my body and they told me you know, "Janice,
those are your battle scars, you know, they're beautiful.
They're amazing, and you should be proud of them." When I went into kindergarten, went into elementary school, my first nickname
was, "broken doll"
second one being Frankenstein's monster. Because of that, I became bulimic for a few months.
I cut my arm a few times. I just kept punishing myself. I kept on pressuring myself to be this perfect person,
no matter the cost.
I realized what I was doing was wrong. I realized that the image that my parents
wanted me in my head of myself was broken, and shattered, and thrown away by myself. As my parents said, my scars are beautiful,
I'm beautiful.
Everyone is made, just exactly as they were meant to be.
There's other ways to
release any emotion or pain. I journal, I
go on little adventures by myself,
listening to music, singing when no one's around,
crying is one of the biggest ones.
You won't be 13 forever. Your relationship will change
with your parents, their relationship with themselves, and with their own traumas will change and adapt. They're humans,
they're superhuman,
often to a fault, and
they care about you, and they're trying.
- Being okay with who you are is
the most important thing, and then
feeling appreciated by those around you comes should come second,
it shouldn't be first.
- A lot of the people that seem like they have it all figured out, probably don't,
so just be patient with yourself, and
just keep doing things that you enjoy, and
discovering who you are, and know that it might take time, and that you can go at your own pace.
It doesn't matter where you're at right now. It's your journey. It's not anyone else's.
Thank you to our brave cast who read and responded to secrets, and to all the brave folks who submitted secrets.
Don't forget to visit our shop. We're running out of items as we speak, and follow us on Instagram.
Tag us in your human good gear, and most importantly, stay inside, stay safe, and take care of one another. See you next time.